you and base Gus on drums I'm lead
guitar and vocals hang on why do you get
to be the frontman I could be the
frontman like Dave Grohl if you wanted
to be the frontman then you should learn
a different instrument
I wouldn't buy the best of two teaching
like a shortcut to enlightenment 3 do
you work here
no favorite moment of the year this far
by now
I got puzzle few maybe it'll be a lucky
chance call me old-fashioned to be able
to hold something tangible to actually
have an interaction for something real
[Music]
soon as we son all of our problems will
be over I promise one of us has to bring
in some real cash where's all this
coming from
got no idea de I gave up my dream so
that you could live yours you don't know
what it costs to create something to
pull your heart out and get nothing in
return
you sold out anyone argue
so I guess this is a it's over she's
moving on associate you the best music
comes out of pain
[Music]
sometimes you have to lose something to
know how much you needed it
I want to give you everything you've
ever wanted
[Music]
please come back
[Music]
you
[Music]
you